thank you very much indeed good evening
it's now worth
5 30 members not of the council
and members of the press and public i
welcome you to this meeting of the
council of the 25th of march
2021 prior to this meeting
all participants have previously checked
that they can be heard
and seen and can see and hear other
members
it is vital that you can be heard and is
preferred that cameras are kept on
throughout the meeting
to double check this and introduce
everyone who is present
at this remote meeting i would kindly
ask that i confirm your attendance
and your role of job title when i say
your name
so going through a register of
attendance members
councillor alban yes here chair
uh member for eastcliff ramsgate
and cabinet member for operational
services
thank you councillora
good evening chair uh counselor for uh
central harbor in ramsgate thank you
thank you councillor ashby present chair
westbrook ward and shadow leader
thank you councillor bailey
evening chair viking ward councillor
thank you
councillor bambridge
councillor bambridge i'll come back
counselor i was on me present
um for westgate board
thank you very much chancellor jill
baffert
mean chair a counsellor for bradstow
award
and shadow cabinet member for housing
and
community safety thank you councillor
robert baker evening chairman uh member
for
kingsgate and chair of overview and
scrutiny thank you
thank you councillor boyd
president for a garland award
thank you councillor braidwood
[Music]
councilor braidwood
i'll come back councillor colin cook
president chair counselor for burtington
north
and vice chair of planning thank you
councillor christendom president chair
councillor for east cliff ward ramsgate
thank you councillor curry present chair
councillor for cliftonville west and
vice chair of overview and scrutiny
thank you councillor day
councillor day i shall come back
councillor dennis evening chair
councillor for garland's ward
thank you councillor dexter uh president
chairman
councillor force and peter's ward thank
you councillor duckworth
president chair cabinet member for
economic development and estates
and councillor for dane valley wards
thank you councillor everett
president chair um councillor from
newington ward and leader of the council
thank you councillor farence
good evening chair councillor for samson
award
thank you very much councillor fellows
good evening mr chairman uh councillor
for bachelor south
thank you councillor game present chair
councillor for cliftonville east
thank you council ghana i'm here chair
uh councillor for saint peter's ward i'm
leader of the green group
and chair of governance and audit
committee thank you
councillor greene president chair and
member for nethercourt and southwood
thank you councillor gregory here chair
councillor for samson ward thank you
councillor heart i've seen you
get here chair councillor for sonic
villages thank you
councillor hopkinson i'm here chair i'm
councillor for somos's montefiore awards
in ramsey
thank you councillor huxley present
chair
a council for east cliff walden ramsgate
thank you councillor keane good evening
chair
council of cliftonville west thank you
councillor cup
good evening chair councillor for
bircherson south and shadow cabinet
member for operational services
thank you now i've had count apologies
from councillor pat
moore councillor paul moore good evening
mr chairman
councillor for being award thank you
councillor ovendom uh here chair member
for never call
thank you i've also had uh apologies
from councillor parsons
councillor linda piper i'm
a chair councillor for northwood thank
you thank you
councillor stuart piper here chair
councillor for northwood ward and leader
of the senate independence
thank you councillor pops chairman
uh councillor potts will be joining us
later she's slightly delayed but will be
attending the meeting
right i'll put that down as in when she
arrives
councillor pugh
present chair councillor forthanet
villages ward and shadow deputy leader
thank you councillor ratticon here chair
councillor chris endenbergwell thank you
councillor roth good evening chair
the councillor for beaconwood thank you
councillor rogers here chair councillor
for cliffs and peggwell
thank you councillor ropa a chair
councillor for phanet villages
councillor rozeki
and also deputy leader of the planet
independence
thank you councillor david saunders
here chair fellow cabinet member for
finance administration and community
wealth building and viking world council
thank you councillor maeve saunders
and chairman thank you
thank you council scoby
uh evening chair uh councillor for
cliftonville west
thank you councillor scott
uh good evening chair uh councillor for
westgate on c
thank you councillor schrub here chair
and counsellor for cliftonville east
thank you councillor tomlinson her good
evening chair
a councillor for westbrook ward and
chairman of the planning committee
thank you councillor towning good
evening chairman
um councillor for cliftonville
cliftonville east
west east sorry now you
get to be sure
member for margate central uh deputy
leader
and cabinet member for housing and safer
communities
quite so thank you councillor wing
oh i'm trying to um sorry sorry chair
couldn't unmute
president and councillor for central
harbour in ramsgate thank you
thank you councillor right board
councillor for birchington south and
vice chairman of the council
thank you and finally councillor yates
good evening chair councillor for
margaret central and cabinet member for
finance administration and community
wealth building
thank you very much just going back
briefly to
councillor braidwood are you with us now
councillor braidwood
councillor braidwood
counselor today are you with us
councillor day
councillor day i shall have to mark
those two councillors as absent since i
have not had apologies
now richard of tender officers we have
the chief executive miss homer
we have the deputy chief executive mr
willis we have the director of
operational services mr waite
we have the director of law and
democracy ms culligan
we have the committee services manager
mr hughes
so moving on if you have any technical
difficulties this evening during the
meeting then please contact one of the
democratic services officers
on call who will attempt to assist you i
would ask participants when you are not
speaking please
mute your microphone this minimizes
background noise and will help everyone
in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been grant ambition to
speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen and i
will then make a note of and go back to
you
once the person speaking has finished
webcasting and proceedings please note
this meeting
is being live streamed for members of
the public
except for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered
for an exclusion of the press and public
from the meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast
on the internet we have some
restrictions on the use of mobile phones
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone growth whilst the meeting is in
progress
do not turn your phone off as it will
make hard
is harder for democrat services to
contact you should they need to
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting
other business and ensure that you're in
a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
general item one apologist for absence
um i have no i i've already mentioned
two apologies are there any other
apologies for absence
it seems not i'm not having any
indications
agenda item two minutes of the meeting
held on the 25th of february 2021
i move the minutes of the meeting of the
council held
on the 25th of february 2021 be approved
and
signed as a correct record with the vice
chairman please second
or second that mr chairman thank you
unless anyone objects to the minute i
will take them as agreed
and i have nothing i take them as agreed
thank you very much
moving on to agenda item three
announcements
now i understand that councillor patmore
has recently been
unwell i'm sure the chamber will join me
in offering
our best wishes uh i'm not
actually aware of any particular details
just simply to say that she is unwell at
the moment we wish her the very best i'm
sure
agenda item four declarations of
interest
are there any declarations of interest
this evening
i'm not getting any indications from
anyone
gender item five petitions no petitions
have been received in accordance with
council procedure
rule 12. now moving on to agenda item
six questions from the press and public
to make members of the public aware
democratic services can assist you in
crafting your question
if you are unsure of the appropriate
wording if you would like any assistance
please look at the council speaking at
council meetings webpage
or contact the democratic services team
who will be only too happy to help you
now six questions have been received
from members of the public in accordance
with council procedure
rule number 13 please note
that only the questioner and respondent
are permitted to speak on the question
and if questioner is not present at this
meeting
their question cannot be put but will be
replied to in writing
the usual procedure therefore agenda
item six
a question number one remember the
public regarding the housing policy
i call in this instance upon mr hughes
committee services manager to read the
questions submitted
by mr dickman mr hughes
are you there mr german
the question is as planet is recognised
as an area of high deprivation which is
likely to be exacerbated by the
aftermath of kobe 19
should tdc be reassessing the housing
policy
rather than building large developments
on arable land would it be more
appropriate to concentrate on smaller
projects
providing affordable stroke appropriate
housing
thank you mr hughes and thank you for
your question mr dickman
i call upon the leader to respond
counselor everett
yes thank you chair and i'd also like to
thank mr dickman for his question
um the council is required through its
local plan to meet the housing
requirements for the area
the housing need assessment has to be
undertaken in accordance with government
guidance
this assessment also identifies specific
local needs for affordability in
different age groups
and the mix of housing sizes types and
tenures that are required
the local plan process looks at the
options for providing sufficient housing
land
including brownfield sites and this is
then considered a public examination
the adopted local plan contains policies
and allocations for a variety of housing
sizes
and types on a different on a mix of
different sites large and small
urban and rural and brownfield
greenfield
in total 30 of the identified housing
land supply
in the local plan is on sites of 50
units or less
and 25 percent of the supply is on sites
of 20 units or less
meeting the housing needs of the area is
an important part of responding to the
deprivation issues in the district
along with many other projects and
programs with which the council is
involved
it's often the case that larger sites
are capable of delivering key
infrastructure
that cannot be accommodated on smaller
sites and examples
are around transport health and
education and indeed affordable housing
the update to the local plan will also
consider future options in the district
for any additional development
requirements
up to 2040 and we intend to hold an
initial public consultation
on these proposals for the update in the
autumn
thank you thank you very much indeed uh
councillor everett
that's very thorough i'm sure agenda
item 6b
question number two from a member of the
public regarding
dog fouling i'm pleased to welcome mr
nib to the meeting
could the questioner please turn on
their microphone and state the name of
the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put
and read at the exact wording of
question that they have submitted to
council
mr nib
are you with us mr nib
i'm being our democratic services
manager is
nodding mr levin's with us
he's not with us he is chairman yes ah
okay good i'll mute his microphone
hello hello mr nip hello
um it's a question for councillor steve
allman
it's um concerning i just wanted to know
what the
council were doing to combat this
scourge of dog manure
on sanet street at the moment
thank you very much indeed mr nib that
was your question as president
of council uh i call upon cancer album
to respond
council album
sorry chair uh thank you for your
question mr nib
firstly it is illegal to leave dog feces
lying around
uh in in public if it is not picked up
you could be fined a fixed penalty
notice of 100 pounds
if our dog waldens and enforcement
officers
can catch them being unaware
your dog has failed or not having a
suitable means
of clearing the dog mess is not a
reasonable excuse
and they will still face a fine
we have over 30 uh text pack free dog
waist bag
dispensers across the district in
strategic locations
of parks open spaces and promenades
also the fido dogs quad
vehicle operates five days a week
picking up dog mess
thank you chairman thank you very much
indeed mr alban of course it is a very
real problem
one that confronted myself when i was uh
in cabinet some time ago
uh agenda item 6d a question
um no i'm sorry agenda item 60
question number three from a member of
the public regarding
litter in ramsgate once again a call
upon mr hughes committee service manager
to read the questions submitted by
a miss kirby mr hughes
thank you chairman the question is as
follows
landscape is a lovely town but the
rubbish is a nightmare
there are lots of groups out picking up
litter voluntarily in the community
but unfortunately it's not enough are
there any plans to employ more staff to
help
keep our streets clean and tidy
thank you mr hughes and thank you for
your question miss kirby
i call upon councillor alvin to respond
yeah thank you for the question miss
kirby um i am pleased to say
that then district council has been
working with the
town council and ramsgate litter forum
on street cleansing in the last three
years
we are this year reviewing bin locations
and the efficiency of emptying these
but there is no additional budget or
resources available
to increase the size of our street
cleansing team
following the high numbers of visitors
to our beaches last year we will be
commencing
our usual seasonal beach and promenade
clearing much earlier this year
on the 29th of march
we have increased the size of some of
our bins around the beaches this year
from 360 litres to 1100 liters
coastal bins are emptied at least twice
daily
thank you chair thank you very much
indeed mr alban
uh just as everyone know councillor
linda potts has now
joined the meeting agenda item 60
question number four from a member of
the public regarding recycling
i'm pleased to welcome miss austin to
the meeting
could the questioner please turn on
their microphone and state the name of
the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they are submitting to
this council
ms austin are you there are you with us
i am thank you chair
um my question is to the ever popular
council alban
um my question is the 18th of march was
global recycling day
fan its recycling rates are poor many
residents have no doorstep collection
and public facilities are extremely
limited in light of tdc's climate
emergency declaration
how do you plan to improve our recycling
rates and facilities
and what targets are you setting to
achieve this
thank you thank you miss austin uh
councillor alvin it's a
tough portfolio of that one isn't it
yeah but it's worthwhile chair thank you
and i thank uh i thank ms austin for her
uh
important question uh could respond as
follows chair
the council offers fortnightly curbside
recycling
collection to 78 percent
of than it households properties must
have space on their property to store
blue lidded bins or containers
to allow collection
the needs for effective recycling
features heavily in the council's
climate emergency change action plan
and the service is committed to offering
readily available and accessible
recycling
to residents there are a number of
public available
recycling areas to go along with the
household waste
and recycling at maxton road margate
this year we are trialling one high-rise
block of flats
for recycling and are also working with
sanic districts council's
housing to trial this at council-owned
high-rise flats we are putting out large
1100 liter recycling bins
at our blue flag beaches and seaside
award beaches
they have these have aperture type tops
which will accept bottle and cans
etcetera
we will promote with clear messaging
on what can and can't be recycled
recycling
is everybody's responsibility
one of the major issues with the public
recycling sites
for example in car parks around the
district
is contamination with non-recycling
waste
which often means that the whole content
of the container
has to be treated as non-recyclable
waste
we would like to further our engagement
with resident groups this year where no
curbside recycling
is available to talk about options
including the potential for secure
community recycling facilities
thank you chair thank you very much
indeed council album
just certain councillors know councillor
simon day has now joined the meeting
gender item 6e question number 5 from a
member of the public regarding the local
plan
once again i call upon mr hughes
committee services manager to read the
question
submitted by mrs wells mr hughes
thank you the question is followed
in light of tdc's declaration of a
climate emergency will the council now
review brownfield sites such as
13 hectares in north bank avenue that
have been identified for industrial
building in the local plan
rather than residential or mixed use and
so prevent the loss of its prime
agricultural land
thank you mr hughes and thank you for
your question mrs wells
i call upon the leader um councillor
everett to respond
thank you chair and thank you to mrs
wells for our question uh in the local
plan we have to find sites not just for
housing but for other uses as well
including employment uses
in all cases this will be a mix of
brownfield and greenfield land
depending on what sites are available
and suitable there is therefore a
careful balance required to meet both
housing
and other development needs in the
district if businesses are displaced as
a result of land being reallocated for
housing
they usually need to find other sites
which might also be on greenfield land
they could also decide to locate outside
the district instead
resulting in a loss of local jobs or
longer journeys for family residents
that they employ
in the last local plan process the
council undertook an assessment of
existing employment sites
including the all states avenue site and
was able to propose the removal of some
30 hectares of land
from older or inappropriate industrial
sites to be allocated for housing
the site at all states avenue was not
removed from business use
it is a brownfield site of about three
hectares
and the site is currently partly
occupied by existing businesses
but it is due to be reviewed as part of
the local plan update work
thank you thank you very much today
councillor everett
moving on to our last question from
members of the public this evening
agenda item six
f question number six uh member public
regarding public toilets in broadstairs
i'm pleased to welcome
mr bridges to the meeting could the
questioner please turn on their
microphone and state the name the
cabinet member to whom their questions
to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they are submitting to the
council
mr bridges are you with us yes thank you
it's for
councillor alban again uh on behalf of
the broadstairs tourism labour
association uh can tdc make it a
priority for all of the broadstairs
public toilets
to be open from the 12th of april in
what will be a very busy season
thank you thank you mr bridget i
told you this was a tough portfolio
counter album back to you
yes thank you and thank you mr bridges
for your question
um i can advise you that all toilets
that are usually open
all year round and those open in the
summer season
will be open from the 29th of march
thank you chair well there's an answer
thank you very much indeed cancer album
that concludes some
questions from members of the public
this evening therefore moving on to
agenda item
7 which are questions from members of
the council
four questions have been received from
members of the council this evening
therefore agenda item 7a question number
one from a member regarding the use of
ramsgate harbour by jet skis i call upon
councillor wing
thank you chair uh is to councillor
steve alban sorry steve you've got a
busy night so my question is
will jet ski users leaving and entering
ramsgate harbour be required to follow
all
ramsgate port and harbour maritime rules
regulations and bylaws as detailed
in associated tdc documentation
on the port of ramsgate royal harbour
marine
website thank you very much indeed
councillor in cancer alban you do seem
ready to answer this
yes thank you chair thank you council
councillor again it wouldn't be right
without having a question from
your good self um the short answer is
yes
but i shall elaborate um all vessels
including jet skis using the harbour
are subject to the published terms and
conditions
and also the bylaws of the harbour
in addition it is a requirement for all
vessels
including jet skis to carry to call port
control via a mobile phone or vhf radio
before arrival or departure
this is to ensure safety of the vessels
moored
or maneuvering in the hub in the sorry
in and about
the harbour of vessels moored or sorry
let me state that again
before arriving or departure this is to
ensure safety
of vessels moored or maneuvering in and
around the harbour
jet ski users will be required to hold
relevant insurance and adhere to the
five knot speed limit
in the harbour thank you chair thank you
councillor oliver
wing do you have a supplementary
question for council no
thank you that was the concern of many
boat owners about the small size of
boats and big boats coming in and the
potential for collisions so thank you
well there's no need to ask you for a
response there councillor alban unless
you want to
you're waving that right thank you very
much indeed councillor wing agenda item
7b
question number two from a member
regarding the margate town
deal funding i call upon councillor pugh
councillor pugh thank you jeff
my question is uh with the announcement
by central government that the margate
town deal has been awarded
22.2 million pounds of of funding
to support margaret's long-term economic
growth and well-being
how will this council ensure that this
transformational funding truly benefits
residents of margate
and the surrounding area
thank you councillor pugh i call upon
councillor everett the leader to respond
thank you chairman thank you councillor
pew for your question as you say
up to 22.2 million has been allocated to
the margate town deal board
of which the council is a member along
with other key stakeholders from both
the public and private sector
and importantly representatives from the
community it is the board who will
ensure the funding is truly
transformational for the residents of
margate
by prioritizing and driving forward
those projects containing a submission
to government
the projects have been carefully chosen
because they will act as anchor catalyst
projects
which in themselves will generate
economic change and some because they
will be key to supporting community
regeneration
in margate which is crucial to ensuring
sustainable change
all of the projects included in the plan
evolve from an open call to the
community
for proposals that met the government's
criteria and will deliver the maximum
positive impact for the town's economic
future
the proposals were considered in themes
for delivery and then reviewed
by the people's panel as the margate
town deal bill did not receive the full
29 million
some of the projects will now go through
a process of adjustment to fit with the
funding allocated
however this work will be overseen by
the board and there'll be further
opportunities for the people's panel to
make an input
this process doesn't mean that anything
will be permanently lost
as margate now has a long-term
investment plan which goes beyond the
margate town deal fund
that you finish council everest all
right wrap that up neatly
thank you very much council pew do you
have a supplementary question for the
leader
i do chair and uh thank you leader uh
for your response
um i'll be honest although i understood
your emphasis on the
town dual board allocating the funding
that the uh
the chair has just recently resigned
from the town deal board doesn't really
fill me
with much hope to be honest um but my i
suppose my supplementary question is
um can you confirm that we as a council
we still have an obligation
to ensure that this money is spent
properly uh many of our councillors
sit on the board um in in varying
capacities as representatives
so can you confirm that local groups
that get the funding will be genuine
local groups and that
funding won't be allocated uh purely
out to further political agendas thank
you very much indeed council of you
call upon counselor everett the leader
to respond well
as far as i'm aware of pew there are
more conservatives
on the town deal board than there are
labour members so i hope the
conservatives aren't planning any
political agendas around
around the funding but i don't think
that's the case um in terms of the
chair of the board residing and he's
done that for um
good reasons which hopefully will
benefit margate a new chair is being
chosen by the board
but yes the council is the accountable
body and we will be taking our
responsibilities seriously
um and we will exercise them as you
would expect thank you
thank you very much indeed counselor
everett agenda item 7c
question number three from a member
regarding birchington high street
i pull upon councillor fellows
councillor fellows
thank you mr chairman and my question is
to the leader although i'm aware that
half of it's already been answered but i
will ask again anyway
will the leader commit uh tonight to
reopening the toilets in birchington
village
and also commit to helping our unique
high street in birchington by offering
the same parking scheme that we had up
until christmas which our small
businesses
state was a real boost after the last
lockdown
thank you very much today councilman
fellows back to you council album
to respond yes thank you chair and thank
you councillor fellows for your
question firstly uh in relation to the
parking scheme that was done at
christmas
um there is no commitment to offer
the same scheme that burtington had at
christmas
at present and secondly the alfa road
toilets and minnesota toilets will be
open from the 29th of march
thank you chair thank you councillor
oliver council fellows do you have a
supplement entry
i do but it was to the lead of our
anyone's uh free to answer someone in
the run-up to the end of the first
lockdown last summer there were meetings
and consultations
with ward councillors and parish
councils to put together a plan to
reopen our high streets
we're just over two weeks away from the
end of the longest lockdown of this
pandemic
and we've not heard anything from this
administration on any plans to support
small businesses
post lockdown recently stanley has been
awarded 191
000 pounds to help our high streets
reopen by our government
can the leader tell me how much
birchington will receive this money
and if he can't answer this specifically
please could he share any methodology he
will use to decide how much each term
will get
thank you very much indeed council of
fellows now of course the portfolio
holder is councillor alban who is
normally
there but you've been called upon twice
councillor everett do you wish to
or should i go back to councillor house
i'm perfectly happy to to respond to
that
you are councillor the reality is that
um
the government rolled out a number of
funding streams during the last year and
obviously the council
put in place uh various measures to deal
with those
to deal with the situation that
situation was new and clearly there was
a lot that we all needed to learn the
community and the council about how to
spend the money
in terms of the uh current the current
uh changes
there's 191 000 which personally i find
a bit disappointing
i'm considering supposed to include an
extra amount to
to deal with our beach management issues
which are specific to coastal
authorities
this hundred and ninety one thousand was
only allocated to us
in the last few days and clearly we are
having meetings to talk about
how we will use it but we already have
things like kovid wardens
and we already have lots of measures in
place around social distancing and
signage
so we i don't think you're going to see
a raft of new and different proposals
coming forward
but i'm sure that this is something that
we can discuss with members
across the council in one of our
briefings and if there are any
particular concerns
i'm quite happy to meet members and talk
to them but this is not a new situation
this time
this is really a return to what we've
had before and i'd also say that there's
a huge amount of work being done by the
finance team
um in terms of the government's
ever-changing rollout of business grants
which of course we're delighted to do
but it is placing a huge imposition
uh on our finance staff and i hope that
all members recognize that thank you
thank you council everett do you have a
supplement we've had that
a gender item 7d question number four
from a member regarding enforcement
within the district i call upon
councillor towning
council towning thank you very much
chair
uh my questions will i i think it is for
the leader of the council council rick
everett or it could be for
um it's for steve albans i beg your
counselor albin beg your pardon how will
enforcement be carried out
to restrict barbecues probation of uh
consumption of alcohol in public places
dealing with anti-social behavior litter
illegal parking across
driveways overnight parking and all
all-night uh beach parties how does the
council propose to patrol
our open spaces thank you thank you
councillor turning i call upon
once again for council album to respond
yes thank you chair counci and thank you
casa tony for your important question
um through our new uh
public space protection order
for beaches and coast our new coastal
code of conduct
our enforcement officers dedicated to
the beaches
will be patrolling proactively and
responding to reports alongside
other members of the enforcement team
and the town wardens
obstructions of driveways is dealt with
by kent
police however we will be patrolled in
areas
where we know this is a seasonal problem
and
deter offenders thank you chair thank
you councillor alvin
council towning do you have a
supplementary question i certainly do
um thank you very much
for your response uh council albin
i'd like to clear up uh some miss uh
messages that we've
uh have been going out on the 18th of uh
of this month we had the cabinet meeting
and at that meeting
council wing raised an issue about music
uh she suggested that she would go down
the beach with her guitar and most
probably with her
swimming friends now in the
pspo it is quite clearly stated
that there should be no music in public
places
in addition to that point also
counselor aldita councillor ashby
raised the issue about overnight parking
now
i understand from an email that the
director of
corporate finance corporate affairs
gavin waite has indicated
to her that people who park on a highway
probably
perfectly legally overnight can be moved
on and that issue was raised with
uh your good self uh counselor albin
and you quite clearly stated that you
would have to apply for an rto
uh to uh ken county council now we
should
here we have two instances where the the
p
the pspo is stating you can't do things
and on the other hand you're saying to a
counselor you can have music
and the and and we're being told oh well
you can also have uh
more people on overnight yes councilman
you can
wind up your question yeah the other
points are
with regards to the um
enforcement officers how many
enforcement officers do we have
currently trained and ready to go out on
shift
and how many chips per day will we have
daytime
any and after hours because
it's too much for um the cabinet member
to answer in one go
could you be a bit more concise about
your question please
because we have chair um who are trained
and ready to go enforcement officers
and what the shift pattern will be on a
daily basis seven days a week
during um of the daytime and also after
hours
thank you very much thank you very much
councillor alvin are you able to answer
uh that question well chair i'll i will
try and remember everything the council
of towning said
um important as they are um
firstly in relation to uh music or
anything else
on our on our beaches uh it's it's
a down to a matter of common sense and
education
and our officers if there is loud music
which is
which is upsetting interfering with
uh residents and visitors on the beach
they will be talked to
and asked to turn it down
someone like as i previously said as
councillor winston once i guess go down
a stroma
guitar on a beach it's probably not
going to offend anybody so we wouldn't
be serving any
kind of enforcement or taking any kind
of enforcement action
again that is that is a matter of common
sense
um as far as the staff are concerned
yes we have one full-time enforcement
officer who will be there
at weekends and at heart and at times uh
there so there will be an officer there
full time
during seven seven days a week um there
will also be other enforcement officers
that are being currently being trained
in relation to
being able to serve fixed penalty
notices
and to and to talk to
and educate people on the beaches and
and on our foreshores
in relation to the parking
let's let's make this clear as far
as uh people camping on our open spaces
and that includes our promenades
whether that be on a whether that be in
a
in a vehicle or that be tense
that is part of the that is part of the
pspo
and they will be dealt with and can be
dealt with as part of that
if they are parked overnight on the
public highway
the public highway belongs to kent
county council not to thank district
council
and therefore a road traffic order is
required
we are currently looking at doing that
on various places of talk to councillor
ashby your leader in relation to that
and we are looking at various places
palm bay westgate
and along the coast in which we can
serve these uh
tros um the only thing
i can't help you out with councillor
towney
is should anybody park across somebody's
driveway
on the public highway or which includes
the pavement
is is unless there is unless there are
double yellow lines that is a matter
for the uh police okay thank you
chairman
well thank you very much councillor
albert and i think you may have
surprised yourself with your memory
there
answering a multiple question and thank
you again councillor towning
uh agenda item eight
motions on notice now no motions are
noted have been received in accordance
with council procedure
rule three and therefore i shall move
straight on to agenda
item nine the leaders report now as this
meeting is entirely virtual the leaders
report has been circulated to all
members
and this evening the leader is going to
read his report to us
so council everett are you ready with
your report i am thank you chair
and i thought that the public who um
i think the public who are viewing this
meeting might find it more useful to
hear what i've got to say
if they're going to listen to responses
to it although it's only four weeks
since my last report to the council
um there have been what we hope will be
two very significant developments for
than arising from the chancellor's
budget on the march of march the third
firstly we have the news as we've
already mentioned tonight that margaery
had been awarded up to 22.2 million in
response to its town deal bid
from the government's 3.6 billion towns
fund the success of this bid is a
testament to the hard work of everyone
involved including the board and its
chair graham razi
the local community who submitted
projects for the town investment plan
and gave their views
and the council itself now that heads of
turns have been agreed
the next 12 months will see a great deal
more work as detailed business cases
must be developed for the projects that
are to be taken forward
after which the funding will be spent
over a five-year period
the board will lead on this but the
council is the accountable body for the
funds
and has an important role to play
alongside other community
representatives
this is an exciting moment for margate
and clearly the intention is that the
projects around creative production and
skills
coastal well-being improved public realm
and connectivity
and supporting and diversifying heritage
assets will themselves generate further
investment in the town
leading to a multiplier effect graham
raising had already let us know that he
will be standing down as the chair
in order to lead the delivery of a new
digital education provision in the town
so a long-term successor will be
appointed by the ball in due course
but his contribution has been
significant and we thank him for that
very soon after the margae announcement
it emerged that the thani had been given
tier one priority
to bid for the government's new
levingling up fund and we moved quickly
to confirm
that thanic will be bidding for up to 20
million pounds for ramsgate
we expect to receive 125 000 pounds of
capacity funding to put together the bid
which itself needs to be submitted by
mid-june in order to be eligible for the
first tranche of awards
and we're already working on setting up
the stakeholder engagement process
although the terms of the scheme are
different from the town deal
the experience of working up the margate
bid will stand us in good stead
and in fact in entas in anticipation of
this new scheme we'd already announced
our rams gate future project
and now we have the opportunity to take
forward some ambitious plans for the
town
this money has to be invested in local
infrastructure with a visible impact on
people and communities
together with officers i've met
representatives of ramsgate town council
to discuss first steps and as in margate
engagement with the community will be
crucial
in designing a bid that commands
widespread public support
ramsgate is already set to benefit from
2.7 million from the future high streets
fund
and has also recently been awarded 602
000 for improvements to the town centre
in heritage action zone funding in view
of the importance of these two
initiatives for rams gate and margate
i'm making some changes to cabinet
portfolio responsibilities
and in future i will be taking the lead
on regeneration issues
particularly in relation to ramsgate
although the intention is that
councillor ruth duckworth will continue
to be involved with the margate town
deal
this will also enable councillor
duckworth to give even more focus to the
climate emergency issue
which is already part of our portfolio
and around which some excellent work is
happening
including the decision on grass cutting
that came to cabinet last week
while the funding for margate and the
prospect of further funding for ramsgate
is exciting
we should not lose sight of the fact
that this apparent largesse follows more
than a decade in which the level of
government revenue supports
than it has fallen sharply when i was
first elected here in 2011
our general fund revenue budget was 22
million
half of which was revenue support grant
from the government intended to help
level up areas with a lower council tax
base
in the financial year about to start the
same budget to spend on our services for
our residents will be 17 million
that is a 23 cut in cash terms
and a 36 percent reduction after
allowing for inflation
in the light of that it is unsurprising
that our ability to deliver the services
our residents
need has been severely constrained in
recent years
the reduction also represents money that
has been taken out of the local economy
reducing spending in fanat with a
knock-on effect on the area's prosperity
so to some extent these government
funding pots represent payback
and they are of course very welcome but
they are one-offs and of itself they
won't help us clean the streets manage
litter and kept the bins better
we will need to continue to do more with
less
i also want to say something to
broadstairs residents since i know that
some of them have asked in relation to
these announcements why not us
the simple answer is that the largest
pockets of deprivation in our district
are in margate cliftonville and ramsgate
the council recognizes that broadstairs
would also benefit from investment
but we have to prioritize the areas
where it can make the biggest difference
although there's been some political
controversy nationally over the priority
given to affluent councils
the title of the leveling up fund surely
reflects its proper application
and this applies within council areas as
well as across parts of the country
we did consult south valley mp craig
mckinley prior to announcing our
intentions
as the government guidance encourages
and i am grateful for his support of the
principle of a bid for ramsgate
i know many people were concerned about
the incident which resulted in chunks of
polystyrene being washed ashore at
ramsgate
on saturday march the 13th and i am
grateful to all those volunteers
including councillor tony ovenden who've
played their part alongside the council
in helping to remove it from the
foreshore
the polystyrene came from top pontoons
which have been moored outside our
district
and have broken loose in the rivers
tower sometime earlier
apart from being untidy and potentially
hazardous as it breaks down over time
the polystyrene represents a risk to
wildlife especially given the proximity
of the triple s eye
unfortunately the smaller pieces can
only be picked up by hand
and there is a risk that more will wash
up on the tide as time goes on
broadstairs was very much part of the
focus last thursday when we held our
first online question and answer session
with residents
themed around beach management this is
obviously a hot topic given the imminent
relaxation of the coveted stay at home
restrictions
and the potential for an influx of
visitors from next week
we advertised the meeting via the wave
and i was delighted that we had around
100 applications to take part
or view the session on youtube and
receive dozens of questions
the feedback received suggests the
meeting was well received and as well as
explaining the measures the council has
taken
and is taking to prepare for an early
surge of visitors
we were able to hear directly from
residents about their own concerns
it clearly helped that we had a good
story to tell around the new pspos
the early re-opening of toilets
including extra temporary ones at
margate and joss bay
the provision of more bins around the
district an additional lifeguard at draw
spa
plans to manage visitor parking more
proactively and improve communications
but we know there will still be
challenges we've asked both our local
mps to press the case to government for
additional funding for fanet
in recognition of the particular issues
we face and i'm grateful for their
support on this
of course the public will always want to
talk to us about things they think we
could do better
and there are bound to be questions we
can't answer immediately and solutions
that we can't offer
but i believe we can build more
confidence and respect by entering into
closer dialogue
with residents in this way the council
will continue to engage with residents
by a variety of methods
and this is an addition not a substitute
but the experience
of lockdown has opened up this new
channel in my view
it must be part of the way we
communicate with the public at large in
future
just as it has been an important
mechanism for engaging members over the
last year
all that said i very much hope that by
the next ordinary council meeting in
july
we will be able to meet face-to-face in
the council chamber
and i think that'll be a relief to all
of us thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
everetty and it was good to hear you
make your reporter
read this evening thank you very much
indeed i call upon councillor ashby to
comment on
or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report
council ashby thank you chair
i'd like to open by saying it's good to
once again hear the dulcet tones of the
leader
delivering his report in person albeit
via video link
responding as i've been doing over the
last few council meetings to a set of
static words on a web page have proved
rather emotionally void
as you mentioned there has been
significant developments for sanet
following the budget
and the conservative government interest
investing in excess of 22 million in
margate
and 2.7 million from the future high
street fund and 602 000 in heritage
action zone funding
both for ramsgate of course the hard
work really begins with the delivery of
any project
and it is vital that the residents of
both margae and ransgate see the
tangible benefit and value for money
these funds will bring
i'm sure that the leader's new role of
taking the lead on regeneration issues
will enable him to keep the members and
residents of thanet fully updated
on the progress of the various projects
and i would ask him to clarify how this
will be communicated
you make mention of the reduction over
the last 10 years of the general fund
budget and the effect it has had on the
ability to deliver services
i suppose it could be assumed it goes
back to 2010
and the note left by the outgoing labour
minister liam burns stating i'm afraid
there is no money
and the arduous task this has left the
conservative government of trying to
balance the books ever since
even as a labour administration you must
admit that the conservative government
has done everything it could to ease the
financial situation brought about by the
pandemic
tdc has directly received three million
pounds of general emergency covered
funding
various other kovic funding worth four
million
for rough sleeping test and traced cv
enforcement isolation payments ct
hardships etc
in addition tdc finance team who should
be thanked for their hard work
they have administered and granted 22
million
in business rate relief 36 million in
business grants
in the summer 20 million of lrsgs and
args since november lockdown with
approximately 2
000 businesses benefiting from these
grants
in all the chancellor has picked 85
million pounds of government funding off
the magic money tree and paid it into
than it
the seven million went a long way to
allow us to deliver a
balanced budget but we must not let this
disguise the financial deficit that
existed
in certain areas of the council prior to
the pandemic
the very recent announcements by rodrick
generic and i appreciate that you've
already covered this but i'll continue
with this uh
this comment brings welcome news of
extra support for our high streets in
the form of the welcome back fund
which we understood than it will receive
191 000
he also makes mention of the high street
task force expert support
as we are some 18 days away from the
great unlock please could you
please could the leader revise what
measures in readiness have been put in
place by the council and when the
traders and residents will be advised of
the details
although leader you recognize
broadstairs would also benefit from
investment
you have to prioritize the areas that it
makes the biggest difference that i
understand
other areas such as birchington westgate
and all the outer lying villages are
less frequently mentioned
and i'm sure they also feel somewhat
neglected even though collectively with
broad stairs
they make up some 38 percent of the
overall population of fanuc
some thought into how these parachutes
could be more inclusive in the overall
leveling of the fanuc picture would be a
welcome exercise
the success of the first online resident
question and answer session via youtube
is a sign of how the council come my
excellent use of technology to
communicate with the fanuc community
our enforced lockdown has driven the
need to find alternative ways to engage
with people
going forward there will be a fine
balance needed between a hybrid of
online technology
alongside physical meetings to ensure
that the democratic process
is not distorted or restricted
i for one am looking forward to
attending the statutory meetings in the
council chamber again
they haven't yet found a way to transmit
atmosphere through a telephone wire
i will close by wishing everyone a happy
easter
which hopefully will see everyone
enjoying our wonderful beaches
in a safe and responsible way thank you
leader
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby some very searching points there
for you councillor everett are you ready
to respond
i am the chair thank you and um thank
you
councillor ashby for your response um i
would never accuse you of
presenting an emotional void i think
we're always interested to hear what
you've got to say um
yeah the uh how will we keep people
updated about the
the investment plans well i think one of
the issues is going to be as we've said
over the next year there's going to be a
little work done on working up the
business cases for the projects
uh that's going to involve the people
involved on the margate town deal board
and hopefully the people's panel as well
so that information that they'll be
actively involved in that
obviously we don't uh act unilaterally
in relation to the margate town
fund because because the board exists
but we will work hard on trying to get
messages out to people
and tell them what's going on but if
they're expecting an immediate
immediate transformation of margate then
obviously they're going to be a little
bit disappointed it is going to take
time and the money will be spent over
five years
in terms of the ramsgate project we're
designing the engagement
um exercise as we speak but i'm very
keen that it's as inclusive as possible
and representing newington myself i'm
very keen that the outlying wards in
ramsgate
are as involved in that as the central
awards because i think sometimes that's
a mistake that gets made in ramsgate
um i just addressed your point about um
about burtington and westgate et cetera
they were actually included in the area
which could have been covered by the
margate town
town bid um so i'm not quite clear
there as i said earlier there are some
conservative politicians on there
including
roger gail so if there's a feeling that
they were neglected perhaps they should
take that up with him
i believe is their mp um
yeah in terms of the funding that uh the
funding situation for the council
well i think most economists are not an
economist but i think most economists
now accept that the government
conservative government which came in in
2010 actually made things worse with
its austerity program and choked off a
recovery that was already in place
but what i would say in relation to the
pandemic is yes the government has
dispersed a lot of funds
um into than it into businesses and
towards the council but this council is
still
worse off as a result of the pandemic
we've got less money to spend
and we're having to do more things and
in terms of the the most recent amount
of money the 191
000 it is a fraction of the additional
beach management costs
and only a tiny part of it i think about
60 000 is supposed to be spent on the
beaches
so um the government hasn't given us the
money to put things put things right
even where we were prior to the pandemic
breaking out but we do appreciate the
fact that they have offered some support
and it's up to us to make the best use
of it and i just want to say we've
referred to the finance staff
i think it's only fair that we talked
about the staff right across the council
because particularly the staff who've
supported vulnerable people in the
community
and have worked in all our key services
and all our frontline workers doing a
very
um a very disturbing and worrying time
i've got a huge amount of respect for
them and i'd like to thank all our staff
for all the work
and let's hope that we're coming to the
end of this period and we don't have to
keep thanking them
because the the emergency is over but
i'm i'm full of admiration for the work
that council officers and council staff
have done
throughout the last year thank you thank
you leader and i'm certain those are
sentiments shared by all members on this
council
thank you council ashby i call upon
councillor reverend stuart piper to
comment on
and ask any questions relation to the
leaders report
councillor piper thank you mr chairman
thank you leader
and mr chairman like many i'm a little
bit surprised that this report was not
published on the council website
in order to reach as many people as
possible during this pandemic
as other reports have been it would have
given a little more time for members of
the public to digest
inwardly all the information that's in
them
but i also agree with councillor ashby
that
voice tone is an important part of
any report
the leader has done well to produce a
bit of a party political broadcast for
this evening and so far we've had a
little bit of a party political
response as well so i hope you'll note
my voice tone and give me a little bit
of leeway
with me most party political broadcasts
go in one ear and out the other
but i hope this one doesn't suffer a
similar fate and i say that because
there are some
real political gems in here
mr chairman who could not rejoice
at the government's largesse i am not
a conservative but it seems even they
have this public spirited character
trait
when it comes to giving away money for
our area
we should thank them wholeheartedly on
behalf of local people across the island
though margate and ramgate are the
intended recipients in the main of this
generosity of spirit i am a servant of
ramsgate town council
for the same people who elected me to
serve them here in this council
and i suspect there are a few of us who
might be just a little bit pleased
that the leader and officers from pdc
are going to supervise the town council
in its approach to making the most of
this cash
the labour-run administration at rtc has
certainly got its own way of spending
public money
and could do with some guidance i feel
so as not to waste it
they will no doubt therefore welcome
their local leaders help to keep them
on the straight and narrow the targeting
cuts
as the reason for our decline is a
relatively easy
shot to fire but the reality is
always slightly different i remember
2011
really well and in some cases the
situation was just as dire then
after 13 years of a labour government as
it is now
in fact the last time i remember margate
and ramsgate high streets being a hive
of business
and activity was as far back as the mid
1980s when i used to come down here with
my children when they were small
tdc at that time had no overall control
and a large slice of independence
actually formed the opposition
the development of westwood cross and
the continuing development of westwood
town
could just as easily be blamed for the
demise of our high streets
but that is perhaps a discussion for
another day
we are struggling with some service
provision but again i think
targeting street cleaning managing
litter and collecting bins
is another easy political shot to fire
a quick look at the corporate
performance graphs provided for overview
and scrutiny by anna thought
hannah thorpe and her team showed that
in the year of lockdown for example
there has been no real significant drop
in these services
despite more cars blocking more streets
because more people are working from
home
tvc does not create litter for the most
of the year the residents of planet do
that
all by themselves leader your cabinet
colleague
is being given more time to concentrate
on the environmental matters
in that portfolio too late someone cried
tdc have just spent millions on a fleet
of diesel trucks to recycle our rubbish
apparently the electric dream is more of
a financial nightmare in reality
talk about novelling a horse just before
the race
still the grass cutting is going well
and that's quite green
or it is until it's been left to lie on
the ground for a while
leader enough benevolence from me happy
easter to all those for whom
it is an important festival thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor piper delivered
with some eloquence
and some amusement a tinge of review
counselor everett leader back to you
for a response yes thank you councillor
piper i think the issue of whether to
read out the report or
or publish it on the website is
something that um
i'll sort of consider from both
directions and and i won't hide from
members the the reason it's not on the
website this time is
is around the election period um when
obviously there are heightened
sensitivities about the use of council
resources for anything political but
this is a political meeting and i'm
entitled to make a political speech so
you won't be surprised do
to be honest with you the main reason i
initially wanted it wanted to post on
the website is
it's quite difficult i think to make a
long speech to a computer
um if you're in the room you can
actually feed off the reactions of
people in room and you get
a sense of how bored they are with what
you're saying or whether they're
interested or whether they laugh or any
jokes you might make
and i think just staring at the computer
um it's quite hard to it's quite hard to
manage
um i don't share all your concerns about
rams gate town council but what i can
say is that
rtc are not the accountable body for
this money tdc is
um but the point is he is an elected
body represented by the people of
ramsgate
including yourself as one of the
representatives and it's absolutely
right
that we should work closely with the
elected ramsgate town councillors
uh all of them not just the labour ones
there are some other parties there i
believe there's even one conservative
um uh so and that's what we'll be doing
um yeah the sort was funding situation
in 2011 in the state of planet in 2011
well of course the conservatives have
been running found it from 2003 to 2011.
uh so i don't think that the labour
labour administration
uh uh that the labour councillors were
actually responsible for any
deficiencies that you spotted at that
time
um still that's the government the point
was the government was funding fannie
what the conservative administration was
doing with that money i have questioned
in a previous uh
a previous council but i won't go back
to that um
i think personally westwood cross um was
the right solution for thanet i think
westwood cross
provides facilities and um and
high street names or has provided them
which who would not have come to our
small towns
and the uh the shopping centers
didn't provide the kind of accommodation
and the critical mass of people
to make them work as stand-alone centres
but they're still a very important and
very valuable part
particularly from a community point of
view um and
therefore we must do everything we can
to support our high streets i'm glad you
mentioned the corporate performance i
mean i think that the new
um the new visibility and transparency
of our corporate performance through the
website which we're bringing forward
through the communications team
it's very exciting i think residents
will like it they'll be able to see in
real time how the council is performing
um and it's much better going to be much
better than just receiving those
statistics
every so often and just on the electric
um
waste vehicles i personally would love
to have seen the electric waste vehicles
but what i do recognize is firstly they
were more than twice the cost
secondly they would have required a very
expensive charging infrastructure to be
put in place
which isn't there at the mansion road
depot and thirdly there are lots of
questions about batteries and
reliabilities
and the reality is we're a small local
authority i think we've got 11 of these
news vehicles
and we can't then we simply can't be in
a position where we've got vehicles off
the road at any time
because what it means is we have to go
out and hire them from elsewhere
and the bigger city authorities are in a
much stronger position and quite
honestly they will have to take the risk
of innovating
because little fanuc district council
can't really do that as much as we would
like
but i very much hope that by the time we
get to replace these waste vehicles
then their replacements will be electric
because technology and time will have
moved on
and i think by that stage it will be
possible and just to reassure you uh
councillor piper on that point i
personally am thinking about buying an
electric car
so personally i'm moving in that
direction and i hope other members will
join me if they can afford it thank you
thank you very much indeed leader i call
upon cancer ghana to come on to
ask questions relation to the leaders
report council ghana
thank you thank you very much um well
i'd like to start as well with the good
news
we of course welcome the award
wholeheartedly like councillor piper
the award of 22.2 million for the
margate town deal
it is short of the original amount bid
for so the team will have some difficult
decisions to make
about which projects it is best spent on
as the leader says the council
are ultimately responsible for this and
i hope all the funds will be spent on
those projects
which most benefit the wider community
of margate
it's also of course good news to hear
that we will be bidding
for up to 20 million pounds of the
leveling up fund for when
projects we hope that when setting up
the stakeholder engagement process
lessons will be learnt from the mixed
experiences of some residents
who put a lot of time and effort into
the ramsgate future high street fund bid
a proper respectful partnership with
residents
is the only effective way forward to
success
the leader is quite correct to highlight
the fact that government cuts
means that there has been a significant
reduction in the general fund revenue
budget
which means we now have to bid for these
one-off funding pots
the change in the way the government
funds local government will inevitably
disadvantage smaller authorities and
those like ours
with multiple issues to address while
also welcoming what support we get from
our local mps on these bids
we remember that they've also been happy
to support government changes
which have led to the defunding of local
authorities in the first place
i of course recognize that the main
focus of attention
should indeed be on those areas of
planet
with the largest pockets of deprivation
though it should be remembered that
broad stairs and the villages
also have issues that need to be
recognized and addressed
i would like to add my thanks also to
the large number of volunteers
who work tirelessly to help clear as
much of the recent
polystyrene pollution as possible i'd
particularly like to thank nick mitchell
of wildlife
conservation in planet who was one of
the first on the scene to alert everyone
to what happened and erase the profile
of the incident
to make sure concerted action was taken
while the clear up operation has
completed
a large number of the polystyrene bulls
will have
dispersed up the coast and out to sea
causing harm to wildlife
a key question remaining outstanding
relates to the remaining eight of these
pontoons
moored up the river's tower with similar
degradable polystyrene floats to the
ones which cause the damage
how sure are we that they are properly
secured and that one or more of them are
not going to break loose
either accidentally or maliciously
i realize they're not in tanic waters
but it is incumbent on all of us to do
everything we can
to prevent pollution so i hope we have
been in contact with
dover district council to make sure that
they are taking eleven
any relevant action required
the incident as a whole has highlighted
the damage that can be done to the
environment by
polystyrene and now might be a good time
to consider a suggestion raised at the
recent online question and answer
session
with residents to ban polystyrene
takeaway containers across the district
as has been done by other councils like
oxford city
using licensing restrictions a number of
residents who attended this session
reported that it was positive friendly
and frank
and we hope that this type of online
meeting will become a regular feature
of the way the council relates to
residents particularly on issues
like cause and concern thank you
thank you very much indeed casagana back
to you leader for a response
yes thank you chairman and thank you
councillor i mean i think you might have
got some good points about the
polystyrene
i mean actually i would say that was one
really good example of why the why the
public meeting was valuable in that that
was brought forward as a
as a proposal and and you know my
assumption was that that was something
that we couldn't do
at the meeting but obviously it's
something that we could go off and look
at
see how other authorities have achieved
that i don't know how licensing would
apply
um how how it would affect license
because licenses tend to apply to new
premises opening
um or trying to do different things but
it's certainly something that we can
look into
and we will look into it and i'll share
your concern about the um the
environmental pollution from the um
from the pontoons i know that um our
officers are talking to officers at over
district council
um and you know we will we will seek
those assurances but
you will as you've acknowledged there
isn't very much that we can do about
things that happen outside our district
um but certainly there is there does
need to be a dialogue
um just going back to the local
government funding i mean
you make some good points um what what
one thing which members might be
interested in is the extent to which
other authorities in kent
still base their budget on the new homes
bonus i mean this council i think gets
about 100
000 pounds a year the new homes bonus
was something that was just been
introduced
um when i was um i took over the finance
portfolio in 2011.
um but we had a presentation at kent
leaders this week in which um we were
told that
at least one authority a quarter of
their revenue budget is made up a new
homes bonus
now we'll have to look at what their
funding is in relation to their need
but it does seem to me that there's some
unfairness here and having a system
which disadvantages static because as we
know
we struggle to get developers to build
houses because of land values
and there is a consultation going on
around new homes bonus and this council
will be submitting a response
but one of the things that sort of came
out of it was although we have some
shared
ideas across kent it's quite difficult
for the councils to have a common
position because some people are doing
very well out of the existing system
and other councils would do better out
of a revised system
and certainly we'll look at anything
which can bring more money into than it
and help us
provide the services that we need to
provide um
and i think that's it thank you council
ghana yeah
thank you very much indeed leader um
that concludes leaders report and
response to them i think really what
goes to show this evening
is that um it's quite evident members of
the public that there's a very active
discussion that
our council does give to all the matters
that concern senate
i think that was very well demonstrated
this evening
moving on to agenda item 10 the annual
report of the chairman of the overview
and scrucene panel
i call upon councillor bayford to
present the report council bayford
yes thank you chairman members will have
seen that this is indeed a very
comprehensive report and i've got no
intention of reading out and i'm sure
you'll be grateful for that
i'd just like to make a couple of points
really it's been a very
full work year for the overview and
scrutiny panel we carried out
13 pre-decision reviews six
post-decision reviews and had three very
comprehensive cabinet member
presentations
we also set up a memorial's working
party which is due to finalize its
deliberations and report
shortly one of the things that we did
that i was most pleased with this year
is that in june
we held a workshop and that was open to
panel members but also non-panel members
and i'm grateful that other members did
come along
and the purpose of that was to identify
potential scrutiny review topics that
would be of interest to local residents
we had a very good debate and as a
result of that we came up with a list of
some
16 potential topics they were
subsequently
put in some kind of priority order and
at the july meeting it was adopted this
list was adopted
and we will gradually be working through
those at least i hope we will in future
i can only talk for the fact that we
started to do it and
if i'm around still we will continue to
do that
some thanks are in order i'd like to
thank the members of the panel
the challenge they provided throughout
the year has been
really strong and i think that we've got
to the bottom of
uh quite a number of fairly tricky
topics and and
i think members much better informed as
a result of that
i'd like to thank democratic services
especially charles hungway
for the support that they've given us
through the year
and made everything run very smoothly so
thank you to them
and last but by no means least i'd like
to thank officers and members of the
cabinet
for their attendance whenever requested
it's the fact that in the past that
hasn't always been the case
um but they have come along and i think
we've had some very useful engagement
and long may that continue i asked
members to note the report chairman
thank you
thank you very much indeed councilman
before um
notwithstanding your reluctance to read
your report out i do know council baker
takes considerable pride in his
chairmanship of the
um overview of scrutiny um um
uh committee uh do members have any
comments for him
i can't no no i can't see him
you're getting off light again this
evening councillor baker
thank you very much indeed agenda item
11
the annual report of the chairman of the
standards committee i call upon mr
tucker to present the report
mr tucker are you with us yes i am sure
good evening to everybody
can you hear me okay chair yes we can
hear you
i like council bayford have circulated
the report
which i'm sure you've all read it's not
all that long so i can't see any point
in me
reading it out as well and taking up
valuable council time
all i'd like just like to say is that
i've enjoyed my first year
um within the standards committee and
i'm happy to take any questions from any
members
thank you very much indeed mr tucker do
members have any comments
i'm waiting but i can't see any
i have one from councillor piper
councillor piper
thank you chair thank you very much for
the report and i did note
in reading it that you pay tribute to
the late
peter campbell and we would just like to
echo that
he was very fastidious in in those
uh things that he was involved is in for
standards
and uh general purposes and so on and
it's clear we are all going to miss him
so thank you for remembering to mention
him
and the hard work that he has done
thank you very much council piper and
that tribute
thank you very much mr tucker agenda
item 12 the annual report of the
chairman of the government and audit
panel i call upon councilman garner
to present this report councillor ghana
thank you
yeah the report um which has been
circulated
provides an overview of the governance
and audit committee's activity
during the municipal year 2020-21
a year which has seen do two different
councillors chair the committee
i was elected chair in february after
the previous chair
councillor simon day left the committee
i'd like to thank him for his work
during the majority of the year and for
helping me
to take over from him i'm pleased to
report that the committee continues to
discharge its responsibilities to
provide independent assurance
on the adequacy of the council's risk
management framework
and the associated control environment
and also endeavors to provide robust
scrutiny
and challenge of the authority's
financial performance
and of its governance processes as
outlined in the body of the report
the committee has been actively engaged
with both internal and external audit
and i would like to thank all the
members who served on the committee
during the year
my thanks also go to the council
officers who have supported me in my
role as chairman
and in the work of the committee in
looking forward to the next year there
will be a lot for the committee to focus
on
in a number of areas and given the
continued governance issues facing the
council and the upcoming governance and
culture review
on the near horizon the importance of an
effective
governance and audit committee remains
critical
thank you thank you very much indeed
council ghana
do members have any comments for
councillor ghana
and i'm waiting for any indications but
i'm not
seeing any
no i'm taking that as none presented
agenda item 11
members uh the yes members allowance
scheme for 20 21 22.
report back from the echo committee
i know that the recommendations detailed
in the report be agreed
with the vice chairman police second
council right our second that mr
chairman
thank you now unless anyone objects to
the recommendations i'll take them as
agreed
thank you at general item 12 the
recommendations from the standard
committee
the full council questions from members
of the public
i move the recommendations from the
standard committee as detailed in the
report be agreed
with the vice chairman please second
second like mr chairman
now unless any objections the proposal
are raised i'll take that as agreed
counsellor whitehead you've raised a
hand
would you like to say something thank
you very much chair
um i would like to speak in relation to
recommendation
6.1 part 2 and i would like to move an
amendment
um in relation to supplementary
questions
for the members of the public the
amendment i would like to propose
is that full council does allow one
supplementary question from each member
of the public
who is tabled questioned at an ordinary
meeting following the same rules which
already apply to supplementary questions
from members
and i moved this amendment because i
think that full council
should be always a reflection of our
democratic duty
and we need to be responsible to the
members of the public
in terms of how we make ourselves
accountable and how visibly we make
ourselves accountable
i attended standards previously when
this was discussed
and argued for it at that point i
listened to
very caring arguments in relation to why
members didn't
support it at that point um those did
include
the idea of vexatious questions it did
include
mention of time limits but all of these
i believe
are easily remedied by the chair and we
are
very ably served in terms of our chair
so
i do believe that this is something that
as
a chamber should be very important to us
i do think that the members of public
deserve a supplementary question and as
a cabinet member
who answers those questions i'm more
than happy to answer a supplementary
question so i would like to put that
amendment before council
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
now of course
as we all know that this was a
cross-party um
a matter of discussion at the stands
committee
i have to say um unfortunately
councilman why ahead
i don't see that as a valid amendment
because
it's negating the motion
um we can take that on board separately
i mean what we can do
is and has been suggested me already is
that we take each of the recommendations
in turn and put them to the vote
and i'd like to pursue that course and
in that way
we can actually get full council to have
a proper full say
um on each of the particular
recommendations
from the stanzas committee
and in so doing i therefore would like
to draw attention uh
to the first one or five
that full council does not introduce an
appeals process for rejecting
questions that's number one can i ask
the monitoring officer
to go through um uh the voting please
miss culligan
miss cunningham are you with us yes i am
sorry chairman i was just saying that
there are a few
comments in the in the chat who have
people who who want to speak
first of all yes well
so first of all there is uh councillor
everett
councillor everett yes i didn't see you
there um
yes what would you like to say well i'm
concerned about your ruling um
chair and perhaps the um actually
monitoring officer can offer some
clarification
because i think in the report it says
that the recommendations
it does offer the opportunity to amend
the recommendations
um perhaps we can be clear about what
exactly council is able to do because it
is a bit frustrating
this is a matter which has been going on
for some time and
if we don't resolve it tonight it won't
come back to council until july
um and then i think it won't take effect
until september and really i mean that's
giving local government a bad name
clearly we need to act according to the
rules my personal view is that this
council's got nothing to be afraid of in
hearing questions from members of the
public
we're perfectly capable with people who
don't follow the rules of procedure and
you're perfectly capable of share of
managing them
and i'd like tonight to pursue um
councillor whitehead's
amendment and i'd like to understand
from the actual monitoring officer what
we are able to do because it seems a bit
ridiculous if we can just
defer until july
thank you very much so are you um
seconding that um
thank you uh miss culligan can i have
some guidance please
yes thanks very much chen thanks very
much council everett um
it's difficult when you've got a group
of recommendations that
you know it's quite difficult to
consider them overall because
lots of people will have views on
particular ones so
perhaps to get a flavor of how people
feel and to allow everybody to have a
say into what they
would like we could have a general
debate first and allow people to ask
their questions
put forward their points of view and
then perhaps what we could do
is we could actually take each
i'm trying to think of the most ordered
way of doing it we could take
each recommendation in order and i mean
strictly speaking you can't propose an
amendment that negates a recommendation
so to say you know
i i don't want not to have a
supplementary question if you see what i
mean
so what we could do is take a vote on
each item
separately and if it fails we could then
say
does anybody have an alternative to
propose and do it like that
and then we have an ordered process of
going through each recommendation and i
suspect
there's probably only one or two of the
recommendations that are controversial
and that that we may have a bit of a
debate about and we can
we can take it like that and if
everybody's clearly
relaxed about it i think i think we'll
get through it without too much
hassle how does that sound so
general a general debate debate first
chair and then and then when
when you feel the debate is concluded
we'll go through each recommendation
separately
i like that and that's that's what i was
thinking of at the beginning so thank
you very much indeed for that
uh do members wish a debate
do we just wish to discuss these this uh
these proposals
more fully counselor everett
would you like to speak i got you down
here as wishing to speak
beyond seconding is there anything more
you say
well i've made my point and i'm grateful
to um to the acting monitoring officer
for um
for for her um ideas about the way
forward i think council should discuss
this
and we should get a view from council
tonight and i'm i'm supportive of that
i am as i said supportive of the idea
that we should have a period where
uh members of the public are able to ask
supplementary questions and we shouldn't
forget that we can change the rules
again
if we find that whatever we put in place
doesn't work we can come back in the
future and revisit them again
but i think not to be frightened of the
public and not to be prepared to
give them the opportunity to ask us a
question that we don't know in advance
um i think that will be disappointing
thank you
thank you very much councillor everest
i've got councillor ghana who would like
to speak
thank you yes i wanted to speak um
earlier
um to more or less say what council over
it said i think we do need to
resolve this issue this evening and we
can't wait
we can't certainly can't wait till july
july or september
i certainly do support that that we
change
um that we amend number two
so that members of the public do have
the opportunity to ask a supplementary
question
and i'd also like to see point one
changed
because i think there there has been a
bit of mystery about
how some questions are accepted and some
questions aren't
and i would like to see an appeals
process put in place
for rejected questions or at least a
proper
reply given to explaining why questions
aren't um
aren't being allowed but i i look
forward to voting on this thank you
right okay thank you council garner
councillor ropa
councillor ropa i had you down here to
speak
yes yes um basically i agree with
councillor garner that um
number one yes we definitely need an
appeals process
um i don't know how many are appealed at
the moment
i suspect not very many um and therefore
you know
to allow just to see democracy working i
think would be a great thing
so then give confidence to the public to
feel that they are being
looked cared for properly and number two
yes the
supplementary questions it must be
extremely frustrating for
members of the public in particular to
ask a question
and get a response that they're not
happy with i have to wait for six months
or more before they can ask the same
question again
and perhaps still get a not a
satisfactory answer so
yes yes please uh let's uh think about
numbers one and two thank you
thank you i i would just point out at
this point though that
um as i said at the very beginning of
this meeting
um there is guidance on the council
website
for the writing of questions and in
addition i have mentioned
that the democratic services team are
always available
to manage the public to help them
forming a question
so in a way that should not be
overlooked
counselor wing yes i also support
allowing residents the the chance to
have a responding question
i feel very bad when they ask their
question and
uh they're given a response and then
they don't they're not they
they're they're sort of not unable to to
respond back it seems a pretty pretty
pointless
uh task actually so i strongly support
this
i would also like to see that where
questions are considered vexatious
or refused that that is properly
evidenced and explained
because very often it's not you just
told your question is vexatious
and there is no justification or
evidence base
for for for refusing that question and i
think we should be opening ourselves up
to more scrutiny through
allowing our residents to ask us
questions
and likes been said on here we should we
should have nothing to hide
yes thank you very much indeed council
wing i don't believe that this council
does
endeavor to hide anything i should add
at this point
my understanding is that democratic
services team do give
explanations as to why a question has
not been properly received
moving on councillor hopkinson thank you
chair
yeah i just wanted to say a little bit
about the idea of giving members
of the public uh the same right of uh
asking the supplementary questions
as we give ourselves as members um i
just wanted to say that
you know it did strike me you know when
i was a nearly elected member in 2019
that it did seem a little bit
uh performative for cabinet members just
to be
reading out a pre a pre-written answer
um
and it just felt like there's not much
democratic dialogue there if you're not
allowing
members of the public to come back um on
what they might find
the satisfactory answer or one that
doesn't answer their questions so
i personally think you know as members
we need to be
trying to you know democratize as far as
possible our relationship with members
of the public
and i think this is a very practical way
to to try and um
improve that and i think this is a
really would be a really good practical
and symbolic
step towards uh better consultation
practices with the public
thank you i think the point was mel
well-made
councillor hopkinson councillor scoby
uh yes i i think we should debate this
and we are doing that um and
councillor hopkinson has pretty much
said everything i meant to say so i will
shut up
thank you councillor
jill bayford thank you chair uh yes
it's good that we're debating this i
mean personally
i believe that um
members of the public are entitled to
support
in writing their questions so i don't
really see their need
for supplementary i think the important
thing to remember
is that if supplementary questions are
permitted
far fewer questions can be asked on each
evening
the time allocated to questions is
reduced and in my mind
it's far more important democratically
that members of the pa those many
questions can be answered as possible
then
supplementaries are allowed for that
reason
i i really do not believe that this
amendment should take place
thank you chair thank you very much
councillor bayford
uh councillor bob baford
thank you gentlemen as always my wife
has said everything that i might have
wanted to say
and i don't have any permission from her
to say anything else so sorry
okay thank you councillor before
councillor ashby
thank you chair um having sat on cabinet
and um
obviously i answered a lot of um public
uh
questions from the public and from
residents
the thing that i'm concerned about is
that if the supplementary question
isn't somewhat structured and as a
response
to the answer that the cabinet member
has given
then it could lead to um
an answer not being able to be supplied
by the cabinet
member um if they are not fully prepared
for it
um so i'm not
sure whether allowing a member of the
public to ask a supplementary question
that that the cabinet member hasn't got
the full answer to
wouldn't necessarily um benefit that
particular resident
um i don't know whether or not it needs
to be slightly differently worded on the
basis that um
the supplementary question must follow
in line with the original body of the
question
because the whole point of being able to
ask a secondary question
is to listen to the answer the cabinet
member has given you
and then to respond to that but previous
experience
and us and i know when i've actually
asked questions myself
is that you do prepare your secondary
question so in a way
you're you're being rather disingenuous
to the cabinet members answer because
you actually are not listening to the
answer and you've already composed your
secondary questions so
i'm just concerned that the the
supplementary question
could be remain unanswered therefore
we've not actually got it any further
forward than where the situation we are
at the moment
and we would respond by um
uh that we would inform them by a letter
at a later date so i'm not sure how we
can actually close that gap on that so
um i'm not sitting on the fence but i i
just don't see how
just a statement that we allow a
supplementary question to be asked
how that actually fulfills the need of
the full democratic process
thank you thank you very much councillor
ashby and i think if my memory serves me
correctly that's one of the principal
reasons the standard committee
they didn't actually have debate that
very issue um
so their time was not at all misplaced
um i've
got councillor whitehead raised a hand
and has asked to speak as well
council whitehead you wish to come back
yes thank you
uh just in relation to the time limits i
do understand that it's very important
for all members of the public to be
heard
but we do also need to remember that
it's within the chair's discretion
to extend that time if necessary and
although
democracy and governance being my thing
i would greatly wish it to be different
and i'm working to make it different
it is quite often that we don't receive
a huge number of
numbers of questions from the public and
so i don't think
that it's a significant danger at this
point that we would overrun
but even if we were to overrun i still
think that our primary function
is to be accountable to the public and
it is within the chair's discretion to
extend that time
in relation to the supplementary
question issue
that was why i phrased the amendment the
way that i did
i do believe that a supplementary
question needs to link very closely
to the first question or to the response
for it to be a meaningful exercise
that said it is our duty
and i say this knowing full well that i
am one of the ones that it falls upon
it's our duty to know our portfolios as
well as possible
so we should be able to answer those
questions
and if we can't if it's something
particularly technical
or if it's something that requires a
particular response and research
then at least that member of public has
been heard in terms of their question
and is entitled to receive a written
response to that
so i do understand the concerns raised i
just still think that it
is a very important and fundamental
democratic right
thank you thank you very much indeed
well of course you may be taken to task
on that
at some future point but nevertheless
well put
counselor roth i believe would like to
speak
thank you thank you chair and i would
like to
give a respect to those they spend time
to put this together
and also thank you councillor whitehead
for bringing the amendment to
uh this meeting i think is important to
allow the resident that we are
represented
to have a supplement and uh question
and maybe guide it like as white had
just said to be close
the question to the first question but
however
i don't think would be any problem if
the person cannot answer
to say we will come back to you with
advice
and then email this answer to their
resident
i don't see that be upset anybody and i
don't think that will be any problem
thank you thank you councillor off
now uh i've got two more after which
i would perhaps think we've spoken
enough enough on this
i've got councillor alban
yeah thank you chair uh just going back
on councillor ashby
um i understand what she's saying um
i think it was clear this evening uh
from
even from councillor towning's response
uh to his first question that it can go
out of
it can go out of contra but you bought
him back chair
and i think that's that's the important
part
that's the important part and the
important part that you have chair
in this uh we we owe it to our residents
i owe it to my
to to the world that i represent for my
residents if they want
as a cabinet member to ask a question
and then have a response
and then have a supplementary question
to it of course it needs to be
guided in relation to it to their first
question
um as councilwoman said i've got nothing
to be frightened of i'm
totally happy to answer any any question
and i just think we owe it to our
residents we give it to
we we give it to ourselves to have a
supplementary question
but we won't give it to our residents
and i just think that's
just not right we need to we need to
vote this
uh in chair thank you thank you very
much councillor uh alvin
now i've got one last one who i shall
hear from councillor ference
thank you chair yes i well actually um
councillor albans just uh said one of
the points i was going to make that i do
think it's important that we send this
democratic message
to residents that we we are happy to
take a supplementary question and it
doesn't give a message of counsellors
just being able to do that and not
residents and the time issue
maybe these things can be reviewed it's
i do think the question session is so
important and as
we've said it's only 30 minutes so that
might have to be reviewed
but it seems unlikely because we don't
we aren't inundated with questions
normally
so i i want to support um
this this this motion um yeah
wholeheartedly thank you
well i'm thank you very much indeed
council authorised i'm not sure we've
got
an agreed uh motion amendment because
sorry uh a amendment because as the um
um officers said um it's a negating
motion um since she's been named i'm
giving councillor ashby the opportunity
to come back
council ashby
thank you chair um i would like to
remind
um members that um
we are an open and full fully democratic
process and as will councillors
the residents have every opportunity to
contact their wall councillors and that
is the first port of call that they
should be coming to
um so i appreciate that they like
um to bring questions to full council so
that the whole of residents can actually
see that but
in the first instance if residents have
may
have a a major issue that is in across
the fall council then i can understand
that
but a lot of the questions that get
asked you know that the wall council's
duty really
is to is to look after their residents
so the first port of call should be
they would their wall councillors the
world council if they can't get a result
then they should go to the cabinet
member
and really i think the questions that
are coming to the full council
can be easily dealt with from a wall
counsellor level
well um i would i would like to be seen
seeing thinking that my residents were
coming to me as opposed to actually
coming to speak at full council
and uh if you like on an issue that
could well be sorted and probably better
sorted
by their own wall councillor thank you
thank you council ashby
now i'm going to wind this up now
because what i'm hearing
what i'm getting from everyone is um
differences of opinion and crossing a
couple
of the actual recommendations uh
it's becoming complicated unwieldy
and as we agreed we do want to arrive at
a result this evening rather than wait
until july
and therefore i'm going to fall back in
first instance on the off the council
culligan's
suggestion that we take a vote on each
of the recommendations in turn
and then if necessary formulate a change
so first of all i'm going to go to
recommendation number one
which reads that full council does not
introduce an appeals process projected
questions um
culligan miss culligan would you care to
undertake the um
the vote please uh thank you chair
i will do could i just perhaps make a
suggestion
uh before we start of course yes
yes because because i think the
uh debate has been around
recommendations one and two
i wonder whether you wanted to canvas
whether first of all we could simply
consider recommendations three four and
five as a whole
without going through without going
through um
all the names well that had been my
intention in actual fact because the
remaining three are have not been
touched on and therefore i'm reading
that they're not contentious
so i would like to have three votes
on the recommendation one on
recommendation two
and then one vote on the red remaining
recommendations
i shall be reading these out so everyone
has clarity what we're voting on
so falling them back on what i did say
the recommendation number one
that full council does not introduce an
appeals process for rejected
questions ms caligan
thank you chair let me just sort myself
out with a sheet
okay i should go through everybody's
names thank you
councillor alban four
councillor ara four
councillor ashby four
councillor bailey for
councillor bambridge
paul councillor jill bayford
four
councillor robert bayford
four four
thank you councillor boyd four
[Music]
councillor coleman cook four
councillor clinton for
councillor curry four
councillor day four
councillor dennis four
councilman dexter councillor dexter
sorry bit of a problem there four
thank you councillor duckworth
for councillor everett
four council of parents
four council of fellows
four councillor game
four councillor ghana
against
councillor green four
councillor gregory four
council of hearts four
councillor hopkinson four
councillor huxley two
councillor keane four
councillor cup four
councillor paul moore four
councilman ovindon four
councillor linda piper
four councillor stuart piper
four
councillor pops for
councillor pugh
councillor ratigan four
councillor roth four
councillor rogers four
councillor roper against
councillor roseki four
councillor david saunders
four councillor maeve saunders
four
councillor savage four
councillor scoby four
councillor scott four
councillor shrub four
councillor tomlinson four
councillor towning four
councillor whitehead four
councillor wing against
councillor right for
and councillor yates four
thank you very much that's carried thank
you very much indeed i felt that was
fairly well
uh in favor uh thank you very much for
that
we can now move on to uh recommendation
number two which i shall read
so listen to it carefully that full
council does not allow members of the
public to ask
supplementary questions
ms culligan thank you chair uh
councillor alban
against
councillor against
councillor ashby four
councillor bailey against
councillor bambridge
councillor jill bayford four
councillor robert beauford four
councillor boyd
councillor coleman cook against
councillor crittenden
[Music]
councillor christendon sorry sorry sorry
having trouble with the um
the microphone there for a minute i i
did put a comment in the um
side box to say shouldn't the normal
procedure be that we vote on the
amendment first but if that's not the
case then
against yes if i could come in there
i think we need to deal with the
original recommendation
first since it was presented by the
standard committee
to see how that fares with council
before we consider the amendment
we shall consider the amendment
obviously if it falls that way
in uh against this motion this
recommendation that's you miss culligan
uh thank you councillor curry against
councillor day four
[Music]
councillor dennis against
councillor dexter four
councillor duckworth against
councillor everett
councillor ghana against
councillor greene against
councillor gregory against
councillor hart
four thank you
councillor hopkinson against
councillor huxley against
thank you councillor keane against
councillor cup four
councillor paul moore four
a councillor oven against
councillor linda piper
four councillor stuart piper
four councillor potts
for councillor pew
thank you councillor rogers four
councillor ropa against
councillor zeki four
councillor david saunders four
councillor maeve saunders paul
[Music]
councillor savage four
councillor scobee against
councillor scott abstain
councilman schrub four councillor
tomlinson
or councillor towning
four councillor whitehead
against councillor wing against
councillor right four
and councillor yates against
chair that motion is carried that
recommendation is carried
so we have the recommendation from
standards
um retained moving therefore
on to a block vote for recommendations
three
four and five and i shall read these out
they don't seem to have been contentious
before
number three that when the chief
executive considers rejecting a question
they should consult with the chairman of
the council first
recommendation number four that
information on the process for
submitting questions
and the support available is shared at
full council
and on social media recommendation 5
that the word limit for questions from
councillors and members of the public be
increased
from 50 to 150. now i've taken those as
a block because
our previous discussion did not
contravene any of those so i presume we
shall all be happy to vote for those
on block back to miss culligan
thank you chair councillor alban
four councillor
four councillor ashby four
councillor bailey for
councillor bambridge four
councillor jill bayford four
councillor robert bayford four
councillor boyd four
four thank you councillor carmen cook
four councillor crittenden
full councillor curry
four councillor day
four councillor dennis four
councillor dexter four
councillor duckworth four councillor
everett
four councillor farrent
four councillor fellows
four councillor game four
councillor ghana
four that's the green
four councillor gregory four
councillor heart four councillor
hopkinson
four councillor huxley
councillor keane four
[Music]
councillor cup four
councillor paul moore four
councillor four
councillor linda piper four
councillor stuart piper four
councillor potts four
councillor pew four
councillor rat again four councillor
four councillor rogers four
councillor ropa paul
councillor roseki
councillor david saunders
oh i've got a thing that says councillor
david some of the zestimating
councillor mae saunders
councilman
councillor tomlinson a four
whitehead four councillor wing
four councillor right four
and councillor yates thank you very much
that's correct
thank you very much indeed miss culligan
um
members members of council i don't we've
had a proper democratic
vote for the um recommendations as given
by the stanza committee in my reading of
it is that they have been
accepted by this council
so thank you very much indeed we have
had a good debate on the matter i'm sure
the public will have had the opportunity
to hear that we have
done our best to defend the corner
appropriately
moving therefore onto agenda item 13
changes to committees
panels and boards for 20 20 21
proportionality i move the
recommendations as detailed at paragraph
3.6.1 of the report to be approved
with the vice chair please second second
that mr chairman
if anyone objects the proposal i'll take
unless anyone objects the proposal i
take it as
agreed and i'm not seeing
anybody nothing is coming forward
thank you now nomination of members to
serve on committees
i turn to the group leaders who can take
this opportunity to advise of changes to
the nominations to committees
panels and boards the remainder of the
2020-21 year
council everett do you wish to advise of
any nomination changes
uh no chair we're very nearly at the end
of this
municipal year which in fact has been
two years because we've never been a gm
last year
um and at this stage we won't be making
any changes thank you
thank you very much councillor calif
ashby do you wish to advise of any
nomination changes
no i echo the words of uh councillor
everett
no change from the conservative
group thank you thank you councillor
ashby
councillor reverend piper do you wish to
advise of any nomination changes
no changes thank you mr chairman thank
you
councillor garner do you wish to advise
of any nomination changes
none from me thank you thank you very
much indeed
members thank you very much indeed that
concludes the business of the meeting of
this council this evening
thank you all of you for attending it's
been good to see you we've had a good
debate
good night good night thank you